NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
WILL TELL YOU WHAT THAT
MEANS AND WHY IN JUST A
MINUTE.
BUT, FIRST, JUST 'EVERYBODY
IN THE COUNTRY HAS A SMART
PHONE.
SPEND AGO DAY WITHOUT GOING
ONLINE IS UNFATHOMABLE TO
ALMOST ALL OF US.
TECH RULES LIVES EVER
GREATER DEGREE.
THE SO-CALLED DIGITAL
FRONTIER IS GETTING FENCED
IN.
NOT QUITE AS BROAD AS WE
WERE TOLD IT WOULD BE.
A HANDFUL OF COMPANIES HAVE
ALMOST TOTAL CONTROL OVER
WHAT WE CAN SAY, DO, OR SEE
ON THE INTERNET, CONTROL OF
ALMOST ALL HUMAN
INFORMATION.
CONSIDER FACEBOOK.
ABOUT HALF THE COUNTRY USES
IT AS A PRIMARY NEWS SOURCE.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE WORLD
THROUGH FACEBOOK.
BUT FACEBOOK IS NOT A
NEUTRAL HOST.
IT HAS A POLITICAL AGENDA.
EARLIER THIS YEAR FACEBOOK
ALTERED ITS ALGORITHMS FOR
WHAT NEWS STORIES ITS USERS
SEE.
AND THE RESULT CONCLUSIVELY
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING TO
CONSERVATIVES ONLINE.
BREITBART, THE NEWS SITE HAS
PARTICULARLY LOST ABOUT 30%
PRAGER U DOWN 30%.
RARE CLOSED ITS DOORS.
SOME SAY IGR IS ON THE BRINK
OF COLLAPSE BECAUSE OF IT
FOX, BY THE WAY, IS DOWN,
TOO.
MEANWHILE PURVEYORS OF
APPROVED ELITE OPINION, CNN,
THE "NEW YORK TIMES," "THE
WASHINGTON POST," THEY HAVE
BEEN UNAFFECTED BY.